Yemen was so full podcast I could barely
hear myself - yeah man the Wheels of
Steel was so full podcast with Felipe
Esparza your host with the most and my
co-host with toes and no buttery and
Lisa spars over here man with the news
facts dates was so fool it's been
raining bro they kind of storm 2018
mudslides
man they're out there trying to blow it
up bro like it's a Katrina or something
it's a Katrina when it's by Santa
Barbara I think you're exaggerating bro
did you want FEMA the truth 13 people
died for ya mud slam bro yeah man what
does the pork in the burn areas well
it's just all the foliage and stuff is
gone hey cuz it got burned out cuz I got
burned out and then when the rains come
it just the mud has nothing stopping
also it just runs right down damn but
but people say it's a much-needed rain
to help out the flood should we got the
rain like a month I'm not the flood no
there's a drought the drought a
devastation yeah man LT there's enough
water to cover the flooding or the water
to cover the drought mostly the water
it's right next to the ocean anyway
forget the alley the desert that's what
I'm saying I found out when we were that
cake concert but if we're crying it for
the color forger takes all the water
should I put on your thing yeah dude but
I mean there's already been a political
deal that made way before that's what we
even started saying that [ __ ] way before
oh yeah johnny-come-lately over here
with the [ __ ] a political discourse
there's I'm worried about that man it's
goddamn it's called I was Jack Nicholson
they were a sequel body
Chinatown are you serious yeah I thought
about the water deal really
yeah I'm a hot in for the beginning of
my heart of balls well that's why you've
been that big old dam that's what that
[ __ ] comes down and goes into a lady
right yeah and then I'm the two jigs I
don't know my own yeah so we're the one
so was I'm kind of Alec confidential a
little bit about that and um
the one with their fool man McNulty he
did another one when he was just kicking
the mobsters out of our lake whoa like
Jewish gangster here in LA Marty Cohen
or some [ __ ] what'd he call ya he's like
what I guess when the Italian news were
coming to the bus station Lansky Mickey
Cohen we keep going pay the LAPD to beat
the [ __ ] out of him and send him back to
New York or Chicago yeah man he did yeah
ruben fleischer he made the movie about
those guys gang then no gangs of all a
gangster squad
my next one would have been gangbang no
but um yeah it was I was uh I'm so man
when I started reading when I read that
Chief Daryl gates chief dog a book I
read his book and when um he said also
he wrote in a book managed to just beat
the [ __ ] out of any Italian that showed
up to LA and sent him back packaged
wherever they came from New Jersey and
they were land they'll get picked up
right there like nobody LAPD waiting for
them there was a goon squad I guess I
know the record there was a name but
yeah and then in a movie that Nick notes
he's in they show that they show them
beating up on Italian food and they sent
him back and then Mickey Cohen did the
same thing and there's a lot of info on
that Daryl gates book come for a good
one bro his first partner was a [ __ ]
Chicano bro from Highland Park cuz he's
from Highland Park - yeah Daryl gates
and that's what he had that story of
like when remember we're like it was
real hush-hush with Martin Luther King
used to come into town and just get gang
of chicks
he used to escort him up
there for him for his son or the mean
drug addict or he talks about him in a
book he don't like GoPro like general
gates a son yeah derp gates his son here
II mentioned that how bad how his son
will be like get off drugs and then also
there be into painting so I'll go buy
her a full paint brushes I'll go buy his
cool paints and then if you would like
give up and go back to whatever he was
doing I had a mongoose is kill snakes
yeah I felt like I walked into a city
council meeting over here bro you're
talking about the appropriation of water
and [ __ ] no we're talking about them but
the water is even a drought then we
talked about that movie they had to do a
lot of water we're talking about
mudslides it was like oh yeah that's
[ __ ] up the people that their their
place that you survived the fire but now
you got to worry about the [ __ ]
mudslide that's shitty man yeah madam
you know what man you know I never
thought about the above you pretty much
saved an apartment
oh yeah you're somebody else pays for
the [ __ ] pickup yeah man you know what
there's a leak in the apartment
everybody's gonna roof or put up that
plastic tarp I put it rocks on top of it
no more leaks come on let's [ __ ] your
water slide up the stairs a slip and
slide right now and on the roof
it was the chapel put a bucket that's
Tarkas Pope what day is straw right
shovel Chapel pulled a couple boys who
knows if that's like a technical word
for or if somebody just called it that
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
nice we're doing a freaking show in San
Pedro I think he knows me you the belly
man Martina production yeah yeah and I
and I had just seen an interview that's
when George Lopez was ha ro and he goes
you know every time it's time to go to
work I put on my suit and I look in the
mirror and I know it's time to go to
work so of course my dumb ass
those are grabs a suit tie I go in the
freakin bathroom at the [ __ ] Sheraton
like an [ __ ] before the show starts I
looked in the mirror bro and I was like
Dumb and Dumber
it's time to go to work broy died a
miserable death a little bunch of cholos
in there and told us that loves them
some Jesus I'm doing jokes about victory
outreach they were not feeling that
Shiva chosen Pedro there bro like
everybody was representing oh dude and
you know and listen freaking not just
roles but Latinos love them some Jesus
bro yeah once it's over it's done
Felipe had a shirt that somebody made
one time it was vodka but he was in the
Sacred Heart of Jesus and it was great
it's a great t-shirt and everybody said
where can I get that but they were like
for every one of those there were like
three people like a lot of food it was
Julian the two at the Ash Wednesday on
their forehead man there's nothing wrong
with that man you know what Chewbacca is
Spanish for Chuy first of all we already
know that you know Chuy is a su so it
really is Jesus no I had a shirt that I
made that had me looking like Jesus with
long hair holding some wine but no no
it's a different one but it said it had
chinga it said don't kill me again
and it's smoking a joint drinking at me
and people were told me it was
blasphemous I'm like [ __ ] off like
there's no way that Jesus is worried
about that [ __ ] kind of shirt I'm
[ __ ] wearing get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah bigger fish to fry maybe that's why
a lot of people starving a lot
earthquake where people are praying for
[ __ ] bro there's no there's no turn
up the offer when you can [ __ ] your pity
to other people Bay I mean for cars I
mean Jesus - [ __ ] it please let it be 21
this guy's there's a lot of praise in
the frame oh hell yeah hard or please
eliminated dub
don't let me get pulled over you know
get locked up don't let me get cheatin
God let me get in I see
don't let this test be positive I hope
those were just freaking I hope it was a
pimple and not herpes
God had to decide you know yeah
prioritize where should I go or should I
go we should go was orgy go they wants
to lose 60 pounds starving kid over
there is a hell nah man that you can
always eat fun before him what
constitutes a prayer is that somebody's
hope are really strong wish a prayer or
do you have to get down on your knees
and do the whole rock you grew up and
now you're rock forever am I like a
little tiny rock and you had this for
your whole life you're lucky Rock you're
lucky Rock Talisman let me tell you man
maybe you lose that rock I'm talking
about you think you're everything's
gonna fall of [ __ ] because you
everything you put every tire believes
on that [ __ ] it still put that rock
right in the end it's just superstition
anyways yeah you know I don't I don't
know I I don't want a [ __ ] on prayer
because there are people who get serious
about people to get really serious and
and you can't like even if you don't
believe in prayer even if you don't
believe in the power problem somebody
says to you hey man I'll pray for you
you can't be it they can be like no I
don't want you to provide stuff and like
that's all when like there's a big mass
shooting and stuff and it's like all
prayers for Orlando prayers for Houston
prayers for this at some point that does
start getting old it's like a
[ __ ] go out there with a bucket
and try to get that water out of it yeah
go out there and do something like what
[ __ ] your I mean not not [ __ ] your
prayers I guess I don't want to [ __ ] on
them but action speaks a lot louder than
freaking words you know and they say oh
well God is all-powerful he's Almighty
let you gotta listen dude go out like
you'd be you'd be better you could sit
there and pray and ask all you want
or you could write [ __ ] down on a piece
of paper write an outline and then
figure out how to take action to make
that [ __ ] manifest in gold that some
people there's some people that write
like like in something real inspiration
about anything and get like 50,000 likes
oh hell that person is not gonna leave
his house all year to do anything oh he
did a little quote you know man [ __ ]
your quote do it he's pain-free
I'm not let you borrow somebody busted a
nice little quote about something like
you know when I think about immigration
and daca I think about living inside of
a diner you know you know and I think
you can help anywhere or they throw it
out there bro everybody than the sad
story all the sudden to compare a
sadness to another just to get the likes
lie to me right now I could bring that
up - you know what when I think about
those Tucker people I think about you
know how my family we snuck in here and
my little brother had took Jessup like a
little girl and we had to just struggle
to get here and watch my HBO special
translate this Wow I don't want to do
that wah wah wah I don't want I don't
want pity
I don't want those those likes because
because I inspired you
I don't wanna inspire nobody my whole
life is not a [ __ ] inspiration oh yes
my son would have told me that when I
grew up I wanna be like you man you
teach you in school I don't wanna be me
right now I put somebody else will have
sex my wife I think I'm somebody else
you know I want to be me you know what
that is inspiration although you inspire
them to be better social medium [ __ ]
developing some voices because some
other [ __ ] comes out yeah they're like
when you strike listen I read it I read
posted something speaking of going to
churches last year we posted all [ __ ]
during during the Houston chinga there
they were talking about
acknowledge it absolutely nobody
some people call it some people say was
a flood this was say the act of God
there you go he gets he got mad and he
sends plagues but I don't know check out
biblical boom you know what here so
here's happy because he's just allowing
gay marriages yeah I think Ann Coulter
said that Roberts also said that Joel
Osteen everybody was [ __ ] on him
don't open doors to the to his mega
church right and so Alfred Robles posted
a thing with pastor tacos and it's a
good pastor and then Joel Osteen and it
said bad bus tour so anyway they all
stopped home with dog focused so check
it out so then I reposted his post and
it got a [ __ ] ton of likes it got a [ __ ]
ton of likes but it also got hey it's
like a he did open the door he's a good
pastor he's a good like people were
pissed and defending him I'm like dude
it's just a [ __ ] reposed right I
don't know the [ __ ] guy but if he
didn't open the doors that's shitty do
it after he got criticism he did it
after they started talking [ __ ]
absolutely I mean is that what we wanted
to make sure it was safe we don't want
people to come into an unsafe building
yeah they don't wanna get a good cook
carpet wet we never no bathrooms to
accommodate every bright fire code if
you come to America you don't have a
family member that's gonna let you
borrow a [ __ ] bedroom or let you stay
in the living room you ain't [ __ ] hell
number you came here without a plan
that's what I'm saying well if you're
the first one to come well then you were
traveling oh yeah if you're Catholic
you're Christian you go to a church hey
not a way we're here maybe help us see
this company I think those days are gone
bro they're still active they're still
where
or the great boil you got to sneak in
and then we'll help we'll help you yeah
they'll help you with no questions as we
well question some questions ask but we
donate to the Dolores mission over there
they have in Boyle Heights they have
started a homeless program for women
older women over 50 which was becoming a
problem so and then they they've always
had a men's shelter but you know they're
still everywhere that's crazy that I'm
okay man growing up man I saw a lot of
bums right they were all old to skid row
I couldn't help all the packs that we
passed that I grow but I couldn't go
with them I couldn't go with them
because I could I didn't think I could
handle seeing the kids face to face
cancer you know like I'm handing this
stuff out and what about no you couldn't
bear to see the kids out I didn't go
with you because of that like I packed
up all the packs with sander we did it
for our would you guys hand out like
toiletries and stuff and grooming things
socks and also for kids with coloring
books books so we had we had a packages
for women you know tampons socks rolling
deep man like Pittock lowriders I never
I never cruise with 50 lowriders man but
man yeah but all planned out bro they
have like they have cholos are hardly
bro stopping traffic on chicken on
shitty streets
yeah to keep it going keep it flowing
bro yeah
we got door we had the Victory Outreach
Security but see you did something you
didn't just say let's pray about let's
go and post it up eh I didn't [ __ ]
wait wait to the camp or the TV camera
to get there good or not like that old
thing it's like there's this whole thing
saying where you pray forgot to God for
help and you say well God didn't send
help
and then God says well I sent this
person like these people along the way
who are there and you're sitting there
waiting he's working God's working
through those people and you're sitting
there waiting for something Holly these
little things along the way you know if
your mom got no hustle man you know you
might gonna have a hustle my muscle Avon
she's so she had no we did on we didn't
starve several times my brother and I
ate at dumpsters my that's freaking
quick like we we do agree my mom babysat
she watched our house was a freaking
team there from freaky no sir sir we had
like ten kids in the house too there was
there was time if not would come like
strike strangers would come knock on the
door hey Estella Senor Aquila Nino's are
you the lady that takes care a kid on
the street
yeah and that dude they would join you
kids and go to the freaking me casita or
go dancing and [ __ ] and they're like oh
yeah no stoppin okay pack up or a
babysitter like but we got a dude that
pays for the babysitter they would leave
these kids the kids would be crying like
they didn't know what the [ __ ] anybody
wasn't my dad's in the little kitchen
smoking and drinking the friggin
they're singing songs the novellas and
these kids are like who the [ __ ] are
these people like where the [ __ ] my
mom and they're screaming and there's
like bunch of screaming kids on a
Saturday night and the freaking moms
were hot dude I remember sitting there
dude off to the ladies
they were dressed for the club dude
little ass [ __ ] Telemundo skirt in
preschool how many kids at a time in the
daytime they would called you like 10
freaking kids on that there be ten
thirty kids and cribs and playpens and
[Laughter]
and we did we the government cheese so
you know she'd go to the church picking
grilled cheese sandwich I've ever had
was through government cheese mom used
to make them forget about it on cattle
chef's keep is grilled abroad you can do
it break a lot of butter put the cheese
first and then pick it up and put in a
bread tell my mom was somebody meeting
she try to make it [ __ ] my god no no no
no she made it was tortillas
yeah dude no we did that [ __ ] my mom
made cheese soup yeah man's like Aldo
day and she'd call it Kyle though the
queso
like did she had a name for it but and
now that I think back I look all
cheering it's like I think to myself wow
she was make all her sounds me she was
making shadow job to I would go she
didn't have a job she was like baby City
and my dad was working my mom spoke no
[ __ ] Spanish you know but but it
didn't stop with you know English but
she didn't stop her from hustling you
know from doing her thing she'd do
convene on Deena bro people's people
don't know what I can do you know
brother you you get like a page 15
people 20 people it's the [ __ ] future
bank that's exactly what it is and
everybody gives a hundred bucks every
week and every week every somebody takes
the [ __ ]
never one would always complain dog whoa
everybody one buddy everybody got the I
know there was some scam artists out
there they all came yeah you knew who
they were you knew who I don't chase
that with a Mexico book sent a letter
brush that little get there before him
yeah like if you need it though right
away you'd say you know what let's start
up India and I'll get the first number
cuz that way I'll come up with a
thousand bucks like this right and now
you're making payments every week to pay
it off but everybody every week
everybody's getting a number right so to
[ __ ] like that she would do like I said
get the freaking food from the church
and I'd go to when I'd go to Mexico do I
remember the way they would cook you
know like I remember there was potatoes
and everything if you had breakfast with
eggs it was welcome papa
you had you had me and have potatoes but
it would make it you know when you got
more [ __ ] kids you know like some of
my uncles and [ __ ] did how the [ __ ] you
can't just buy mistakes where everybody
Martin usually by yourself but hit that
big a 10-pound [ __ ] Julie so [ __ ]
cats go when I hear like some people
like when I hear like comedians you know
like a pretty much talk about how how
their parent struggles man you barely
talk about the struggle or ten years ago
well why are the southern issue don't
want to cross over to white people no
more jobs no more ain't nice I don't do
the [ __ ] cross bro whose poor people
how suck into Rick Ramos the other day
Ramos Ramos Ramos versa University yeah
and and we were talking about we're
talking about how he always had beans at
his house like that was a state like
that was but the first time he didn't
have beans every day is when he went to
know when you live for [ __ ] you load
area too bro hey listen look there yeah
the [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] thing
that you but no no no the one that says
born you know
[Music]
you know with older money Mario your
[Laughter]
pity
did you win and now with the baby coming
and everything we can use the money for
[Laughter]
dream crush right there man [ __ ]
Bobby Bob's the Bob he's the one to move
the family out of the [ __ ] the woods
brought back into the city of pacoima
he let's get the [ __ ] outta here II had
an apartment I have a Harley I'm taking
that chick with me [ __ ] pick up your
guitar let's get the [ __ ] out of here
and it went super coil my bro
he wasn't a hero he was a hero he was
selling weed bro to help us a family
right and I heard this [ __ ] this dude
he's jamming bro this will finally find
something cuz you know what bro I don't
give a [ __ ] you I break one of your
brothers
it's the ultimate painter every other
members gonna find what what's up art he
got Picasso had brothers yes my god that
one of them would be like the jackoff
King or something you know he didn't
want to be the jerk-off King he want to
cut it off as ceramics bro but [ __ ] that
up but like everybody everybody
everybody like if you're like everybody
wants to get involved we don't I'm
surprised none of my family members do
comedy bro they don't they haven't each
other's all [ __ ] up means I know that
funny unfunny [ __ ] bro your brothers oh
yeah bro what are they doing like one
like one brother boy the fat one
I wasn't even funny but like this black
woman sleeping and then you're right
look at her lip look look at pressure
sleep or something like that what it was
damn they were funny bone racist dog I
mean I could be racist
I could be funnier than baño bro this or
or what we decided to do switch from
being gentle to being Jewish is
unsanctioned so you doing other Jewish
jokes you just did for the chunks to the
body of the Jewish person or the
comedian yeah it's a comics that that'll
say you know I'm part black and then
those black jokes
yeah exactly for that one white dudes as
I'm a quarter Latino my stepfather's
Latino hey I'm married I Latinas like so
I can do the jokes I hear it a Filipina
so there you go I can do Filipino jokes
I wanna marry a Jewish guy a Jewish guy
[Laughter]
just pray about it I'm into great cheeks
[Music]
how they [ __ ] house the [ __ ] Park
hands going brother
yo yo yo yo three yos three yoseob's
hooter gives her an extra yo what's up
you gotta go Chi cago and look for that
guy bro yo yo yo yo bar yeah I know I
you know what every time I go to Chicago
I think about you're going to Chicago
little time myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
neither one of them had a credit card to
check into the hotel way to meet you to
1:00 in the morning really get back bro
to check into the hotel row there no
[ __ ] credit cards hey but you know
what though at 30 I didn't even have a
driver's license so I don't I mean I'm
not gonna talk that much [ __ ] you got
one before you got a ticket away right
yeah yeah I got it I had it a few times
in both of these guys had they went to
college a little bit didn't I don't know
Rocky's a college graduate you get
flooded with credit card offers in
college I got my friend you [ __ ] it up
but I think that that's their situation
I don't think they've ever had one Wow
well you know what don't blame you their
moms [ __ ] up the credit already but
yeah Lucy card but but but he's [ __ ]
what is he he's like he looks like he's
freaking 1920 that's awesome nice
upcoming show upcoming shows looking at
over here looking like [ __ ] barb from
stranger things Doubtfire up here the
Apes a smart one the coolest monkey in
the jungle gym you know even in a plan
of the year bro the gorilla will look
dumb as Wednesday and the chimpanzee who
running shade and the Gibbons will of
[ __ ] you the main ones are the Wizards
you dropping knowledge yes Caesar is a
chip yeah muscle bro there were some
boys I'm further the further separation
no separation within their own community
yeah and the bonobos are horny as [ __ ]
which ones the bonobos the ones with
like a red but I think so I don't know
I've heard that [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] on the
[Laughter]
upcoming shows I'm coming show me
tonight Chicago January 12 at the big
theatre first to a sold-out 2nd show is
almost sold out it might be sold out but
it might be sold out late Saturday New
York City
January 13 PlayStation Theatre with Papa
kiss hosting [ __ ] Luis Guzman that's
right for Milo yeah but younger bro from
the Lower East Side
January 20 spotlight 29 Casino January
desert diamond casino in Sawadee toh
Arizona these shows are gonna be without
me Larry bubbles brownie McGhee or
murder and I think Johnny and Marty
Martin and Rizzo are going to that one
as well
the Johnny's gonna be in Tucson with you
okay it doesn't even matter whatever
they don't know who these people are and
Carboni Carbone from Goodfellas oh yeah
looks like young Joe Diaz in some fool
the day before is on dude looks like a
young Joey Diaz talking that [ __ ] one
guy that's right man
Yemen favoring first or third Naples
Florida off the hook comedy club with
[ __ ] what's in there captain Brian
captain Brian bro in the fish January 19
January 19th
19:09 19th we have a couple of things
going on you're coming to Los Angeles in
March March 23rd at the Novo downtown LA
Live but there are two shows that night
we have some ticket sale events all on
AXS calm
January 17th there's an MX presale if
you're paying with Amex you can buy
tickets on the 17th at 10:00 a.m. the
password is Felipe VIP fel IPE
and that's 8 X s calm on the 18th
there's another presale for listeners of
the podcast and social media fans we'll
be announcing on the social media to
10:00 a.m. on January 18th
the password is Felipe that's on AXS
calm but wait there's more what
how could there possibly be more in the
19 January 19 January 19th we're doing a
meet-and-greet meet-and-greet in Boyle
Heights at primera cosa selling tickets
in person that day as well so you can
bring cash you can avoid the ticket fees
from the online sales after the think
about $25 there's gonna be $25 yeah it's
yeah whatever the ticket price is it's
just that and no fees if you buy them
with credit card at the police they're
gonna be what 35 I don't I don't know
what the fee is that a excess charges it
might be around 7
ten bucks it's not like Ticketmaster
fifteen or twenty anyway but if you buy
them in person that day on the 19th with
you that's starting at 10:00 a.m. I
think it'll go till about noon that day
there gonna be food there's gonna be
some food we're gonna we're providing
some food and coffee and limited
supplies while that lasts get there
early vegan chilaquiles made by the
vegan taqueria talking about loving
answer Raul they make good food so he's
making chilaquiles and something else
and it's gonna be some pastries too and
then there's a regular pastries they
have there at primera cosa and then the
coffee before sale free they're donating
the coffee too so it's for free - so um
and then after a while they're gonna run
out of it they're not gonna serve that
stuff anymore
but I think a couple hours should be
fine and then also we're gonna sell
vinyl albums
yes vinyl albums and really people sign
them if you buy them there as well good
pictures like this is gonna be fun I'm
gonna take your lunch at 10 in the
morning and be there and then go back to
the office
yeah take your break and go over there
around everybody oh they're in Boyle
Heights thinking about coming over there
and ask you they could say a poem right
now [ __ ] welcome to a bar after we man
I'm thinking of bringing up social
consciousness over here please for
Latino X people who are woke man but you
gotta find someone that's gonna say yes
to you that's so [ __ ] funny because
that is the movement now bro there's all
these places words like there is poetry
and and let's wake up and let you guys
give me a kavika none of those people
are busted not a dollar for a charity or
doing charity work or you know or
helping
walk dogs there's a lot just a little
just a little places by my house broke
where people walk there every day a man
and he does here need help yeah can you
take those three dogs for a walk and
it's going for a walk bring them back do
people let up a joint go back home
awesome how hard you got to do it man I
don't think it'll take a lot of effort
for anybody do this donate one over your
time for charity you know is that what
the country can do for you and what you
could do for the country for your
community is that water done oh man that
badly took apart [ __ ] you Marty so and
Christmas bro holiday extravagant bro
did you have fun I had fun did you have
you know I have fun well to him or Lisa
about it you know we're right for
chilling and we're watching people's
stories that went to your extravaganza
show in Long Beach then that one fool
man like I saw these people getting
[ __ ] up in a bus station
it's a [ __ ] train station what you
thug love yeah then go in the bus
station to driving then F who walks away
with a buy no bro that's he and then he
got he got to see a stripper it was a
little blue yeah you know and he got a
pot man we know man wait not only that
and edible as a fan I think that's um
and the fan of Martine or George or you
Phillipe enemy of offending everybody
man you know what it wasn't a Stromberg
answer for that guy like Oh total
immersion package so we uh we put it on
as a podcast we got to edit it because
the sound was kind of really choppy so
we had to cut down so this is when you
cut in during communion time right so we
had communion with with the blood of
Christ which I thought people were gonna
be offended by and not come up oh right
well though the wine first does they
come come get your blood or blood of
Christ and I poured 13 cups maybe 14
because I figured well I figured I
figured you know these people aren't
gonna come up they're gonna think
yeah and we weren't trying to be
offensive with it at all yeah absolutely
and so next thing you know the whole
[ __ ] place stands up and we're
sitting there like Hooters pouring
freaking wine down people's throat from
the bottle because we ran out of Cubs
but what's crazy you could hear G Reilly
after we gave the the bread no he said
he said dip it in the blood it tastes
better
we had the miracle drizzle which was the
Medicaid drizzle and stuff people lined
up for that we had mistletoe
oh nice sandals dude and then we had the
dating game which was a [ __ ] show that
was a [ __ ] show that I was oh dude it
was all freaking let me tell you
something I'm mad that she went straight
for the ass put it in my thang you know
you know this sort of way to get to it
and [ __ ] like she was doing porn in a
now and [ __ ] she knows - you doing porn
in the 70s in the 70s you gradually
gradually you know get to the ass like
she stayed up she opened with it how do
you want your date to go I want to kind
of put in my ass pause okay game over
you know what's crazy I was still trying
to keep a [ __ ] semblance of freaking
you know like decency yeah hell no bro
you were practicing I think as your bro
I can't wait till next year Brooks I
know next year gonna be bigger but well
you know we're doing you know what you
should just stop just up like Krampus
and your son who does you're just some
little German Santa Claus with the code
yeah you know you know what we you know
what we what we're doing we're actually
going on a Valentine's one right but
we're doing a we're merging Oktoberfest
which is a drinking holiday oh [ __ ] with
[Laughter]
so we're doing pepto professed heart
Stravaganza
spell that [ __ ] with two dots on the top
right so we're gonna have drinking love
games more communion freakin more day
love games
I like that [ __ ] love games
we're doing that [ __ ] back at harvelle's
and we got a few people lined up for
that [ __ ]
listen bro I have fun doing that and the
people had fun like you said that dude
made it an experience he do that fun
yeah everybody had a great freaking time
and all it is is like just combining all
the a DD thoughts that are in my head
and saying you know why I can't be the
only person that thinks this [ __ ] is
cool you know let's all [ __ ] just
hang out on a Monday get [ __ ] up and
and and do whatever the [ __ ] we want you
know yeah that's what's cool dough cuz
it's Underground to it feels like it's
all low and dark dog hell yeah bro I
think next time bro like like the back
of the the backdrop Ross you just have a
[ __ ] a bunch of Christmas movies just
playing a background yeah well [ __ ] and
you know what bro I hope I'll [ __ ] you
up [ __ ] and brah I'll [ __ ] hire some
Christmas Carol real work real words
yeah about the [ __ ] show on the
Christmas Day extravaganza my true love
said to me yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
[Music]
that's the thing we like during
communion when they usually ask for
money we passed out the basket that [ __ ]
had bud they have freaking arrow balls
it had condoms they had [ __ ] rings
it had Lube it had all couple when I
walked off [ __ ] what's a [ __ ] ring a
[ __ ] what the same bad it's like a thick
rubber band yeah well it could be some
people tie a shoelace a [ __ ] message
oh he put a [ __ ] sandwich bag wrapper
and his penis and run through the
rubberband bro you could have for
anything else but a what Oh saran wrap
or maybe like a sandwich bag in
subpoenas and wrapped it with a [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] yeah yeah it keeps you hard
and it keeps you from coming and now
they send the ones that we gave out
hello vibrators on them so now it's
[ __ ] vibrating on your freaking on
your on your huevos and on and on right
and on her who sponsor this somebody
sponsors did you bother yourself I just
had a bunch of stuff [ __ ] kinky
awfully go he's out of food but they
wanna party to end oh oh
what's next Christmas shopping people
like to get down dog they do and it's
like for a Monday dude I was pretty
freaky it was a freaking Monday it was
freaking awesome and and like so the I
did the ice house the other day at the
red bands show and those some dudes in
the audience and they're like hey we
heard about your heart Stravaganza we
don't want to miss it because let's talk
about that what's that no one yeah the
new ones are February 12th which is a
1-over fast and what and and Valentine's
Day so it's true oh man what's up man
how's it going man
hey you know what you killed are you
killed it on a [ __ ] podcast Thank You
Man
what uh when we played it back we edit
it down and you there was a point in
time where you said oh man it feels like
I'm on a public access show that was
hysterical
holy [ __ ] cuz we didn't hear it in the
moment but when we heard it later when
we played it back we were laughing so
[ __ ] hard when you said that caller
sleazy friends bro if you have let that
member me out man I think the dating
game would without a control man George
Perez was [ __ ] when when he hit up
that Duty's oh how are you gonna hide
show up for the first date now full set
almost show up with two eight balls or
two grams of coke and flop I mean now
side together
and then and then freakin striker said
well I'll show up with some toys
it's natural toys shop what some big
striker what the [ __ ] tours gots oh man
hell yeah
so what is a foodarama who chemo what is
the arm that the new one you are doing
the heart Stravaganza so we combined
Oktoberfest and Valentine's Day so that
everybody who's in love got their heart
broken they come and we're gonna do some
drinking games and you could either
celebrate your lover cry about tears of
joy so what have Sebastian 13 oh come on
our King [ __ ] uncle to Big Easy
that's funny ass anybody coming out of a
cave we should have somebody come out of
a goddamn cake bbw night yeah listen
it's just I like the whole circus feel I
really do because that's what it was all
like a [ __ ] psycho Holmes right - the
dog yeah it was a freak show and at
first we were trying to keep it like to
a certain outline we're trying to follow
an outline are you one of the guys no
[Laughter]
yes absolutely because more gas and less
extra cuz it got really like we lost the
control those reins really really quick
Jake I buy a horny broom and then and
then that dude was loaded my furniture
friend was freaking wasted standing up
screaming and [ __ ] but here's the thing
I told hooter I go you know what we've
told these [ __ ] it's 420
friendly it's freakin gonna be an
extravaganza and everybody made it their
extravagant I [ __ ]
it's an extravaganza
[Laughter]
[Music]
I catch my breath
pop animals passed out she was charging
$5 for I'll take a picture but I won't
do the horns unless you pay so Jake who
knows Alex and at least that were then
make it out but you know I'm gonna
invite Jay the drummer ed a groupie
there bro Gracie oh I'm [ __ ] sweating
dude that was funny yeah bro when a
language with Nicki to boost himself Oh
like what that's why I stopped cause I
never anything but that's how I used to
be back in the day we'd walk into a
party a those are the guys from
slaughter yeah dude that's crazy about
high school fool there's always bands
and there's always a band in the high
school or a couple bands and they're
kind of like famous get the chicks and
[ __ ] yeah but after that it's over it's
done it's done I still get people that
hit oh man that I used to be in high
school Bastille is gonna see a movie
called um Tammy Tammy patty cakes bro
who's heinous about the little white
shake that she wants to be a rapper bro
but but dude her mom used to be like a
rock singer and never made it bro
there's a hair band owner who I lead a
Ford era yeah don't Jed you know that
right and I'm [ __ ] but dude she's an
alcoholic bro you should see her bro she
just stopped all heavy metal and goes to
the carrier does karaoke and everybody
say play that song March or whatever
right then she sings it bro it's like
she's a rock star again bro I want to
watch that show watch it blow your
[ __ ] come on so much [ __ ] bro it's
depressing bros likes louder bro yeah we
ordered an Amazon it's called Tammy
patty cake patty cake dude she's like a
white a little trailer trash it's like
that like there is like a bar with a
load trailer trash chick it's not on our
netflix agro eight-mile then do this for
me it's all like when you seen a bunch
of movies you can see the formula where
this is this is heading and then when is
head into that part of the formula of
the movie that you know already though
you're like no please don't don't get
you it is a pair of the wrestler and
it's good but embarrassing at the same
time it's it like the wrestler no Mary
more embarrassing no sad the rest of the
badass is great [ __ ] oh Willy we
gonna combat gonna jump into jumping out
of a building the [ __ ] was making some
money for some good gigs you went to go
get his hair done he's got a [ __ ] tan
and when he'd have no money he's I'll
doing his hair by himself his own nails
here no one's gonna [ __ ] die when I
woke up in that he hooked like okay a
lot of comedians do this - bro like
those are national just a big ass there
was a big wrestling match and that we
chose over those who just sits there bro
and then hooks up with somebody cuz I
get my little shout out yeah but he was
supposed to be somewhere else that yeah
man with a daughter with his daughter
but he wakes up after a [ __ ] you know
what does that [ __ ] happen in real life
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Jesus Christ oh praise God do you see
guys a lot you know what we we go to
shows together still we actually did we
went to women took nasty alright Alex
Alex is bar mom Beach like maybe a month
before they know a week before Monty was
Jenna judge now seein Breakfast Club the
guitar player from [ __ ] minor three
yeah he was there too Ryan Baker no
doesn't matter religion yeah he was
there at the [ __ ] it was a great [ __ ]
show everybody was singing oh how are
they do badass do you know what they had
sound problems but they were badass
[Laughter]
the only work they were together bro oh
my I can't even [ __ ] breathe I can't
even talk for hours three at least it
was hours it was hours of content and
see here's what happened so we had a the
feed we had it on Facebook live right
and we're gonna pick it up from there
but the sound kept dropping so it had a
lot of drops so we had to there was some
of it that was just you could not
[ __ ] hear it so this time we're gonna
[ __ ] we figured it out you know what
listen it was the first [ __ ]
extravaganza bro you got some [ __ ]
problems when you can see when is the
heart what was it called on the 12th
February 12 the the Feb it's a long name
I don't know why we did it but we just
thought it sounded cool tober fest heart
Stravaganza there it's gonna be a link
on Martine Moreno calm and yeah dude
it's gonna be [ __ ] a party
it's [ __ ] it's what it is is a freaking
party with [ __ ] just everything you
wanna do you can do and without us
yelling this time nobody nobody else
yelling male exotic dancer for the
ladies ladies you know the women like to
go out in packs before but I think
they're the single ones exciting dancer
[Laughter]
crunchyroll a male exotic I can't afford
it is we got a half male half woman
a [ __ ] uh dude whatever [ __ ]
exotic dancer it is it'd be [ __ ]
awesome
that's a good idea yeah I need a male
exotic dancer why not I'm doing a show
February 11 in Oakland with David for
Vanessa no fortune Finster preacher
Lawson from AG America's Got Talent
Bruce Bruce what's up yo leprous Bruce
it and myself and then the twelve which
why we've come back home oh I'll stop by
bro so you know well you're not really
planning it like how they're gonna be
like what I want to know how is gonna be
but it'll be outline director someone
that not involve initial are you lady
actually direct the show like to
everybody Martine yeah five minutes so
nobody knew who got the thing we were
they were so we had so this is what
happened we had the computer on a few oh
we learned a lot so we have the computer
screen on there and and the messages
were supposed to come through most of
the queues and so that way we could keep
the show moving but we forgot to [ __ ]
get the password don't know what a
search of the laptop uh-oh
and we were like what's the password
lottery looking I'm looking at her and
he's looking at me oh my god I just
closed the computer it she goes mr.
Perez what to do we just said hey you're
gonna host the [ __ ] dating show and
damn that food did it yeah amber focus
ed you know what he singles damn this is
the improv dating shop improvisation
he's learning bro ambush with a hosting
job and you know what him and side
dictate he [ __ ] killed they did and
what you know what's funny Philippe it
when we are when we when we started
planning it and we we said we should
have Philippe comment and see if he's
available you know I go you all be
awesome is if he came up and just
described everything that he just saw
them and we didn't tell you that we
didn't tell you that but you came up and
immediately you started talking about
the [ __ ]
the dating game you're like herpes back
there that should give me a quote so
lose your sake you're like you started
talking about that then you started on
Baja everybody came up for free [ __ ] no
yeah so you did you instinctively did
what we visualized you doing which was
[ __ ] awesome it was preordained we
were funny men who were standing in line
you're right they really knew was [ __ ]
up but they also appreciate I don't know
that it was [ __ ] up though we didn't
we don't get offensive and no no
offensive but yeah but it's still kind
of like it makes people think like I
said there you get it was and and you
know that dude that came in the bus that
you said that oh you talk love
he carries a pocket Bible in his back
pocket which I signed for him because I
was preaching giddy to a stripper at a
stripper show where I met that guy and I
wish I had a Bible and I mean a lot
right on cue he pulls it out of his back
pocket big Felix the caddy
this is cold you know what I like
preaching bro not preaching but just
teach and I like teaching I like
teaching the word has such a bad
connotation Bronco love going to do yeah
and also I I like to think of it as just
you know like a freaking congregation
Kobe with you know cold don't thing with
the bad ones bro exactly yeah always but
there's good cults this minds a good one
we're just gonna make the world a better
place what the show be known
what they they were well alex has put
like we're like if I if if you go to a
hardcore show with that dude Alex he's
like known in that community he knows a
lot of man's he knows he used to book
shows at a place called the PCH Club
over in the border of Wilmington in Long
Beach and so a lot of dudes that are
blown up now like big big names the mini
Manor from there and and he went and
[ __ ] and so he they all passed through
the PCH Club on their way to a gig it
was like the place that you did a gig at
on your way to a gig and it was he did
that for years bro he was booking bands
and he did it like he rented a studio
that was supposed to be a recording
studio and he's like [ __ ] this is away
from everything there's no neighbors
nobody could complain about the [ __ ]
noise there's plenty of parking so he
used to charge five bucks and do
hardcore shows and he ran that [ __ ] for
years they found out about it and they
they had this dude from the LA Times
come and do an interview on him talking
about you know this this club and how
long it been this and Alex told them
everything you know they're giving them
props Brawl on your later yeah a day
late well by this time he had already
cut it they they shut him down they came
and shut him down because you've got no
permit you know that and that was the
end of that [ __ ] but the LA Times took
that mo'fucker down like a blessing and
a curse at the same time a man you know
what because it's like what the beauty
of it was was that it was underground
yeah like as soon as it became that then
they're gonna shut it the [ __ ] down and
but yeah he had a boatload of people
there constantly so and so he knows a
lot of fools and he's well known in that
circle but the fact that there's a whole
new crowd of comedy fans that know about
him and that's freaking crazy and I'll
be ganna be Joe it was all the dream
woman he used to read up some Circus
magazine oh I used to read circus cool
up in the magazine correct
Joe the Kerrang circus hit Parader all
that [ __ ] Parader remember that [ __ ]
well then one called circus right yeah
maybe
tbh Tiger Beat
tiger beetle you guys like Donny Osmond
on the or : I used to shower bedroom
with my sister's right so one wall hello
here one wall had a shitload of pictures
of heavy metal posters and the other
wall had [ __ ] My Little Pony no
[ __ ] who's that [ __ ] guy
lucky no because Blackie on General
Hospital big dog yeah wait John Young
John Stamos Christopher a queue with a
bad boy Christopher Atkins was the other
dude that she had up on all these now
waiting well wait before Johnny Depp's
time so all these pretty boys were up
there and I'm not a bro
yeah Scott Baio was one of them and I
remember freaking chachi's a number one
time I had this Motorhead shirt on and I
was standing in front of her mirror and
[ __ ] and I'm looking at all these
pictures and I had a somebody took a
picture of me it looks like a selfie but
it's not a selfie and I had let me on my
wall and so somebody took a picture of
me and I'm standing there with a shirt
that says give me some Motorhead and my
hair I just got out of shower so it's
all wet and I try to do like a sexy face
like John Stamos picture and you can see
that [ __ ] in the photo of him
somebody posted up [ __ ] Gabriel Aces
Christmas party and his trench coat
hello brother I don't know let's talk
about that died bro because you're butch
is coming up right March March 21st and
many minutes - yeah and his birthday
that's right
what happened bro you guys had a cake
for at the Laugh Factory
take us back was I there for that humor
teen you and Benny man and and [ __ ]
when I party like killer - they're
premature I'm building that baby I don't
remember the last Factory bro
was I there yeah was a birthday party
you were rolling deep with that fool
yeah cake
laughs fact how [ __ ] up were we you
were [ __ ] god damn my god you threw you
pick up the kick it through their hair
shut the [ __ ] up
no way yes I don't remember this
and then cuz I remember that you know
how much beers I've thrown since me and
I they band our food and eivin and i are
no no you don't we stood up clean
I did not I wasn't all the way I was not
there for that I was not there we I
remember going boy after the whole she
was all [ __ ]
I can't I was not careful I would
there's no way I wouldn't remember that
[ __ ] that's pretty goddamn big but I
can't think of anybody else they'll have
a cake fight with him many men ah I'm
gonna ask you cuz Benny man I used to
get pretty loaded up in there it was bad
bro I was not but I was doing my baby
minute Latino night though oh yeah see
that was the [ __ ] that's when can see
when Benny started when Benny took over
I was already not I don't even know if I
was going up over there anymore
yeah it wasn't turned that that cake
fight there's no way I was there I would
remember that it was like it was like
the were celebrating our birthdays it
was slightly shadowing frank lucido pops
me Benny I think everybody's around the
same [ __ ] time Hooters birthday's
Tuesday back yeah
Capricorn season hope your buddy coming
up on Saturday right it right if right
into what the twelfth how do you cheat
cago where we go G 35 39 40 Doug the big
four Oh big 15 over the other is in a
receding Barea boy one Garcia now 35 no
way yes shut the [ __ ] for dog 34 35
hegemony nah
Rizzo's 31 4 well yeah but ain't super
young yeah compared to that fool Wow
well how are you honey I'm gonna turn
2700 dog can do chapel who was 17 when
this fool was like nine yeah I guess so
sorry 84 I just I guess I you know what
time it's like uh it's funny bro time I
think I think to myself like like cuz my
mom like now when she looks at old
pictures like well show her pictures of
her right and she got hit though that's
not me that lady's old because she's got
Alzheimer's right so she doesn't hurt
she's like [ __ ] no that ain't me who's
this old lady you know she's like
talking [ __ ] about that but you don't
you forget that you stated that you I
looked in the mirror and I saw this
[ __ ] gray and I'm like you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I know it was [ __ ] great but I
just never really gave it thought right
like I I know you know when you're eight
you're aging and you're getting older
yeah and [ __ ] like that wait wait one
but one day you reflect and you're like
holy [ __ ]
wait a minute I'm not a young man
anymore not I'm not a kid you know and
and it's crazy because you still feel
it's not like when you get older [ __ ]
changes in your brain and all of a
sudden you're [ __ ] all grown up that
never happens
no you're still having the same thoughts
and everything else but your body is
aging and then once and when you look
and you're like holy [ __ ] my mind never
kept up with this [ __ ] my [ __ ] still
stayed in my slaughter days and my
[ __ ] you know I just stayed in my
freakin mind all this to romanesque
battle inside so so I looked and I said
holy [ __ ] I'm I'm a grown ass you know
man I'm an older man now what was it
happen yeah but it was like a like a
realization that holy [ __ ]
I am that older dude now I've always
been an older dude I feel but now I'm
I'm like I've grown into this this this
older dude that [ __ ] I didn't know
existed I I didn't realize I didn't see
myself as this much of a veteran or an
older dude harpus match great the carpet
matches the drapes
whatever homes you know but you don't
you don't look at yourself man like dude
they were looking at myself a little
people taking photos of me on stage cuz
I see myself on the front I don't see
myself on the side on the side so
whenever an authority some side photo I
said man who the [ __ ] are taking him
against part I mean but yeah it's true
when you start seeing them I start
seeing the pictures of my of my grace or
my lone causing [ __ ] and I'm like yeah
dude I'm getting [ __ ] up there and and
then what the [ __ ] I have a 27 year old
son I got three great
[Laughter]
but you know what I'm glad that I made
it to this and I buried a lot of fools I
mean I've been to a lot of you come from
a narrower [ __ ] got [ __ ] up
on drugs though huh bridges ya know
there's a lot of dudes that got buried
you know there's a lot of dude that
didn't see 40 cuz the liver shut down
you know cirrhosis of the liver yeah
drinking drinking you how do you drink
that much before [ __ ] 40 like how much
it could have gone or did you do it bro
you know what I stopped drinking for
like ten years and I think that's the
only thing that saved me that's the only
thing that saved me my liver was able to
rejuvenate itself for a little while and
in that way I can [ __ ] keep on going
right because I you know I and I don't
go as hard as I used to there's no way I
can't go as hard as I used to I drink
yeah a lot of him I mean I do get I do
get loaded but I don't think I know
every time yeah well you know I don't
know that I [ __ ] do you ever go back
to the crazy day like when you think
right now I don't believe in cars and
brush
I'm not I'm not gonna say that I that
I'm that I don't drink like I used to
because I don't enjoy it it's just
because I can you physically physically
can't go that hard if I go hard one
night I am worthless for 24 hours like
ridiculously worth done I can't even get
out of [ __ ] bed I can't imagine like
I'm out there right now I'm back out
there going on to shows and stuff like
that right and there's a lot of cocaine
there's a lot of cocaine in Los Angeles
let me tell you that right I think it's
on the upswing it's on the upswing it's
huge it's [ __ ] on the option and and
and and when I see people going hard I'm
like how in the [ __ ] like I can't even
imagine a [ __ ] rager like that and
then still trying to function the next
day I'd be kameen if I'm worthless with
[ __ ] booze what the [ __ ] would happen
if I started doing [ __ ] lines again
and don't get me wrong I had a blast
doing that [ __ ] and it's not like I'm
saying oh it was it was all horrible
that was horrible times but there was a
lot of good goddamn times too
so and and if I could if I could still
physically do it I don't know that I
wouldn't to be honest if I could still
physically do it but I [ __ ] can I'm
afraid I'm afraid that if I do [ __ ]
bombs I'll die like I really that [ __ ]
crosses my [ __ ] head like there's no
way my heart could hang with it anymore
I don't think it's funny man when you
speak Spanish bro you could make
anything sonico sweetheart
come on bro Nalini de una Lomita right
let's Osito make anything so like a
sweetheart even drugs English thank you
doing heroin like come on bro puncture
oh well it depends yeah you gotta say
'hey todo because if you say throw gas
that [ __ ] sounds crazy
oh yeah brother almost up for mars
robust katrina got busted with his pipe
and [ __ ] his weed and he blamed it on me
and then i go over there wave con
rodrigo o el drug addict first I did
food
first time these fools spend the night I
mean you know man I've been paid dues
bro like we were open making that fool
just hanging out not working just
hanging out for nothing bro oh yeah I
just really hanging out and I was temple
like real nice guy to make his mom live
him I live in a one-bedroom and I feel
led to fools by the night oh and the mom
was living in her bedroom with her
sister and if we were in the front with
Ivan bro but there was five people in a
one-bedroom yeah a [ __ ] seven and
dude and it's all [ __ ] over his iris
mom's lunches from the school but she
was nice talk she was we would be three
days at his house and then one day I his
house unlike one day out of the weekend
and his so two dates what else yeah well
yeah one day at a pool though Ivan has
poor school our high school photo and
all that dude
in high school before dad passed away he
was [ __ ] fat brother Butterbean and
it really passed by the faithful pad by
the photo last real hard way the whole
[Laughter]
family's really fat you look at them
down there not that baby brother velvet
and painted on a rope or something
hey doesn't that seem like a [ __ ]
lifetime ago now for I can type I can
still smell this the smell of it but as
far as the time that's passed by not
really really awful like I think back to
[ __ ] when I was a little kid now that
seems like a [ __ ] eternity but now
that's like last week to me so to me ten
years seems like a lifetime really
yeah [ __ ] yeah like because so much
[ __ ] when with the more [ __ ] that you
[ __ ] see and [ __ ]
you know like what's that [ __ ]
[ __ ] show with that crazy [ __ ] guy
was of the baseball player [ __ ] Willy
he's found and down there yeah yeah
Kenny Powers right there's a scene where
they go eight do you remember the blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
and he's like dude sometimes you have so
many memories in your head you got to
get rid of some of the [ __ ] older
ones to make room for newer ones you
know and and at that moment you don't
really like I don't remember you know
but you know what that's the thing it's
like when you see so much [ __ ] and every
week is [ __ ] and not to overuse the
word but epic and you're doing epic [ __ ]
on a weekly [ __ ] basis it's hard to
keep track of what happened a week ago
two weeks ago some of the [ __ ] that is
the most memorable is some of the most
like crazy [ __ ] because everything else
kind of runs into each other you know
you you start doing so much [ __ ]
that's why I said it feels that to me
things feel like a life you were go this
happens to me a man you ever go to a
town and you would a man you start
looking around I've been here before
yeah but you do remember you don't
remember the town's changed cause you
don't know that you've been there that's
not literally happen yeah like you done
this room but you don't remember doing
it anymore
that's crazy and it's crazy but it but
it but when you're in it so long and you
do so many places and you see so many
faces it just it all just becomes this
one big thing and then you start like
the things that stand out the most are
the things that were really [ __ ]
impressionable how about the people that
you meet and you have a good time but
like you go out and meet other mo'fucker
your ass yup then you come back a ten
year eight years remember that summer
party brought or remembered on but I
probably did mention the name bro Cesar
oh yeah nice yeah and that happens all
the [ __ ] time because you're kind if
you know what I there's no there's
lyrics on a song that says I made
sixteen one our friendships every solid
one our friendships every evening which
means that every [ __ ] night that
you're out there you connect with X
amount of people and it's solid
solid for that one hour and after that
you never [ __ ] see them again that's
a life of a rolling stone like a life of
a rolling stone somebody that's on the
[ __ ] Road and when you meet that many
heads it's hard to keep track of them
you have to [ __ ] stand the [ __ ] out
you know most of the time I don't
remember names I'll remember nicknames
you know there's a dude at the Chicago
improv think about that yeah I don't
know her name
and but I know who you're talking about
you know there's to work the door right
uh his name Palmberg in Schomburg yeah
and [ __ ] quit Ivan I have no white
boy and [ __ ] Ivan called him the
sandlot cuz he looked like the [ __ ]
chubby kid from the Sandlot and forever
i frickin knew that guy a Sandlot and
because that's what the [ __ ] he looked
like cheetah ivory was dating and and
and I'm nope nobody knew her name and
then gave us a that John Lennon she was
right there I remember John Lennon yeah
she was there I remember her I remember
some chick named hippie IRA broker here
yes
that [ __ ] popped a Viagra and a
[ __ ] in another one he probably popped
two chili pills in his 20s bros
[ __ ] in its prime rock dude he
[ __ ] dislocated this chicks hip so we
didn't know her name we just called her
hippy commercial hip hip hooray
[Laughter]
snap that's freaking crazy
that's doing some serious damage they
play located because she probably was
laying on a bad part of the bear leg
down and with a thrust must have broke
it or something or it was the one and
she was laying down in an awkward
position dude although just hit it
straight down the middle dawg well this
busy to tell us you'll do gymnastics as
earlier probably broken or she might
have had it that [ __ ] might pop up on
the rag and she just [ __ ] didn't say
nothing Mary she was in a circus
circus Olay she's a hoochie in the box
little prayer for her pray for that hip
heart foundation February 12th
harvelle's in Long Beach go to Martine
Moran real calm and listen I got tickets
what's that don't you think it's 10
bucks 10 bucks people you know robbing
anybody cuz we don't know what kind of
[ __ ] shows gonna happen I want people be
like I paid too much for this [ __ ] we
believe you you know so so but what I
want to say is that when we when we came
on here the first time we had just
started the yo yo yo podcast we had just
started and now we're like 30 plus
episodes in and people a [ __ ] ton of
people like literally we were three
episodes in the first time we came on
here yeah people are looking at us like
yeah did you talk to me in a year if
you're still doing it you know and and
and I get it because that's the that's
the the thing is like a lot of people
start let's take a stand with it so we
do have fun right I do I have fun and
but here's the thing
we're still getting people hitting us up
saying a big portion of people they came
and started listening was because you
put us on on the what's up fool and so
thank you for that because they gave us
a huge jump start time jump start my
favorite episode and we're still getting
we're still getting a lot of love do you
have like 80 thousand views this is
right on red Martines 100,000 now you
got beat out ah yeah beat out are we are
Emilio who like no on the top so Gil
Carrillo nice talker and a couple of me
clothes chapo because he was first a
baby bash MK frog were first but you had
one night when we move to audio boom and
right away the first week was like
65,000 Wow thank you very much for
bringing back it should be longer he
wasn't a song a trilogy you wanna know
the behind them we behind slaughter
behind the music and what happens to
that guy I'm a German forklift
we should have committed a we should
have stuck it out we should are your
friends man growing up you thought that
this food was gonna be like he was here
potential but somehow along the way
nothing
Jake Jake what do you have smart yeah he
was he had a full scholarship to USC
academic scholarship in the 1980s and I
shouldn't say that he didn't a month or
not that he's traveled the [ __ ]
planet really he's gone to every World
Cup for the last God knows how many
World Cups so the dude does get around
and he's done a lot of like great stuff
but he had he loves he still drinks and
his liver shut down a few years ago and
he's still partying I don't know how the
[ __ ] still alive he is like [ __ ]
like like Frank bro from [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's my very own Frank but he had
a scholarship a full-blown academic
scholarship to USC in the 1980s and he
just partied his ass off he just he just
liked the party you know and and he went
[ __ ] hard dude dude there was the 80s
he lived in ghost town in Wilmington
that was freaking crack cocaine alley
have across the street from his pad they
were slanging crack while we were
partying in his front yard listening to
[ __ ] Judas Priest and [ __ ] like that
right
there'd be [ __ ] times where [ __ ]
would get raided you'd hear gunfire
people would be running up and down the
street we'd [ __ ] duck and then after
the [ __ ] was over we'd go walking down
the street trying to find rocks that
they were throwing and then just [ __ ]
start hitting that [ __ ] you know it was
crazy time you know when you when that's
where you live and across the street is
the [ __ ] crack house and your block
is a driveway for this [ __ ] I mean what
what uh what hope do you [ __ ] have
you know what I mean it's like I'm not
saying that everybody that grows up in
that environment is gonna end up crazy
but chances are if that's all you see
you're gonna [ __ ] end up [ __ ]
partying a big chunk of your life away
you know so I think he had some of the
most he's very very [ __ ] intelligent
dude but like the part
yeah bro ah my porn star passed away bro
rueful uresa Bertrand you reason
Bertrand what happened oh D pills bro
how old was she
I don't know member III saw the career
star bro uresa you resolve it Tran bro I
saw her career star boy it started off
on bangbros I'm sure doing girls only
girls three video dudes then it started
off was being in a video was was a girl
and a guy then he moved on bro then I
went to a no then I was done with her
nobody yeah man it was like all of a
sudden well that another points were
passed away to a guy right over a
comment right everybody was giving her
flak no cuz she wouldn't sleep with a
black guy she didn't wanna you know tire
risk of getting affected Wow China died
too right but I was a while back yeah
China she wasn't a porn star well she
was she did one port at one point yeah
it was like the WW something like a like
a wrestling gangbang in [ __ ] yeah comedy
shows coming up anything let's see
that's on the 12 the 16th I'm over at
the same I let you know that over in
Oxnard Level II live in Oxnard with a
record mumble Rico air Mambo and I think
George Perez is also on that show and
then the 17th I'm at the Ontario Ontario
improv with the smash brothers they're
there they're freaking twelve-year show
dude they [ __ ] hand that dirty show
out there for 12 freakin years never
book me once really they're intimidated
no but that shall be going on man those
masks brothers I'm Chad and Cory it's a
nasty show and
they'll be doing it for a long time
they're about to hit their 12 year
anniversary and and they've had well you
know they they they opened up for
Ralphie main yeah last freakin ten years
or something up until he he passed away
we just we just did an interview with
them that we're gonna be putting out I
think next week or something with with
with both of those guys and and they we
got to talk to them and and and get to
know them a little bit more because
other than seeing them at shows I've
never really liked like hung out with
them they haven't they got a crazy
[ __ ] life their stories where stories
are it's a wild crazy [ __ ] story I
mean their dad was [ __ ] slanging coke
and and these guys were getting babysat
by [ __ ] at ten years old by [ __ ]
hell's a biker chicks you know I trip
every time somebody says biker they
immediately say Hells Angels and I I
shouldn't have said that you know but by
bike by by biker chicks and these they
bike somebody's property
oh dude these dudes had some walking
stories so that that was all about
diapers and cowboy boots Billy Lisa grew
up brothers oh my god let the biker guy
who show what bro no the [ __ ] past
our foods without everybody in the
neighborhood are blowing and they were
nice to everybody and then the earth you
trailer trash kid's diaper and a cowboy
boots a Harley shown you some speed hey
no do you know what's crazy though it's
like it's just because people are like
in a like you know like when you said
you went out to the homeless people or
skid row with lowriders people are so
many associate lowriders with being like
you know laws and gang activity but
they're actually out there doing good
just and there's good and bad people in
every freaking section of people and
[ __ ] but absolutely so you know when you
think about people that write the right
motorcycles are motorcycle clubs they do
a lot of good [ __ ] that do they do bad
[ __ ] absolutely but the politicians do
bad [ __ ]
abso-fucking-lutely there's good and bad
everywhere it's a gang in the gangs just
for you it
protocol spotlight twenty-nine people
mirror Yemen or people we just found out
right now I'm at the Coachella show it
spotless when a casino is sold out so I
guess I'll catch you guys at the Ontario
improv in the fall I'll be there in
October Oktoberfest
so your shows coming up yeah I'll be at
heart valves next Tuesday the 17th and
the following one - I think it's a 25th
and they're running and then I'm running
comedy night at Horizonte yeah every
Tuesday looks a comedy in for less the
student named John all while coming in
but less yeah so you know you get a
little bit of comedy they do some live
podcasting and delivery do they do they
get a good crowd on Tuesday there yeah
that's pretty good
the Canadian yeah you could just go to
the go check out who the next Tuesday
yeah go check out who the Moran oh man
and if you I'm big timid I'm a shy right
now man you're looking for a date no we
don't you want to impress your lady you
want to show her you know you're into
the arts you know something a lot of
guys would like to take the chicks on
with her sweats on bro I've seen my show
but I wear sandals to the show really
bro just hope you get really dressed up
bro bring your lady man Tyler you take
her to a show to go to eat somewhere and
then till you see the hooters show up
for the Marino the hooter show and now
know a little bit less man tell you man
women like that man there's all the
[ __ ] he in a regular
[ __ ] he likes to read he's more
fancy I love the way your voice changed
when you did that whole intro bro that
was [ __ ] smooth man yeah thank you
come on man look at the icy chief that
are so dressed up and there's a
either bro who Spock is a big fan but he
didn't get dressed up like it's he's
wearing some dirty tennis shoes like
he's from Canada hey you wanna [ __ ] up
the shoes in the snow me the 16th of
January next Tuesday at the break
me Chinese rookie and rizona special
guests and all the proceeds will go to
Isaac [ __ ] Martinez he's all right
man you know all right
he's skinny morphine's that funny man
when part of jeggings would probably I
showed up to the show he goes you had a
bank watching each of the show then I
brought him up he goes well this guy had
more they said that this guy had more
friends I would like more friends in
whoo yeah dude bro it wasn't [ __ ] oh
that's trolling upfront like was great
here hey oh man thinking again it comes
out to me after a show with a par I grew
up watching you then what am I [ __ ]
Mumia watch immunity seek a bond beta I
saw you with the [ __ ] barbarian
brothers oh that's all right people you
know what stop magical Shikata
Felipe worldcom also man please don't
review the show tell everybody how much
you like to show say good things about
my team on the on the right of review
and taking everybody out there who'd
been subscribing I'm the worst awful
podcast and every Apple store in LA yeah
the full set of videos bro of
subscribing the words of a podcast to
all the laptops inside yeah bro that's
how you give your bro we got to number
157 that dude that gangster though
that's some dedicated fans right there